ذكر مسؤولون اوكرانيون ان القوات الروسيه
شنت امس الجمعه هجوم صاروخيا وصفته
بالاوسع والاعن في منذ بدء الحرب على مدن
ومقاطعات اوكرانيه استهدف فيها منشات
الطاقه والمباني السكنيه
وقال الرئيس الاوكراني
قوات الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه اسقطت 60
صاروخ الروسيه كانت تستهدفه لتزويد الطاقه
والتدفئه واضاف زينسكي ان الهجمات
الصاروخيه الروسيه المستمره على بلاده لن
تغير في ميزان القوه في الحرب
الارهابيون الى مثل هذه الكميه الهائله من
الهجمات الصاروخيه ليصل جزء منها الى
اهدافهم المدنيه التي هي بالاساس منشات
تزويد الطاقه والتدفئه لا يغير ذلك القصف
ميزان القوه في هذه الحرب لا يزال لديهم
صواريخ كافيه للعديد من ضربات الهائله
ولدينا ما يكفي من التصميم وثيقه النفس لن
يعيد بناء انفسنا بعد هذه الضربات